[Music]
you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirror
columnist susie boniface and the
conservative commentator
tim montgomery they'll be with us right
through until
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
well the mail leads with plans for a
so-called amber watch list for
international travel
which would give the government the
ability to switch countries to the red
list
without warning the mirror describes the
combination of coveted rules and
upcoming
bad weather as holds hell
the telegraph understands that at the
height of the pandemic the nhs drafted
plans to deny
hospital care to people who were already
in nursing homes
in an effort to keep beds free
the guardian says employers who won't
give jobs to people who haven't been
vaccinated
could face legal action according to the
financial times a group of conservative
donors known as the advisory board
some of whom have given as much as 250
000
pounds has been having regular meetings
with the prime minister and the
chancellor
a tory spokesperson told the paper
government policy is in no way
influenced by the donations the party
receives
the times says that more than half of
householders can expect an
increase of 150 pounds a year to their
energy bills
the biggest increase for 10 years
the express says the government stands
to make a six billion pound windfall
from continuing to impose
inheritance tax the sun
speaks to eastenders actor sid owen
about his drug
and alcohol use and romantic exploits at
the height of his fame
and the star has bad news for fans of
pies and pastries
they could soon be banned at football
matches
shock horror and we're joined tonight by
suzy boniface and
tim montgomery uh we'll get on to that
story about the pies but let's start
with
the mail and there's just more heartache
for people
hoping beyond all hope it seems to to
travel and have a holiday abroad that
countries that they might be in could
easily move at any second from the
ambulance to
the red list the headline their summer
holidays in europe on
brink tim i think this is beginning to
get
quite ridiculous jillian i think we have
ministers we have officials who have
acquired a lot of power
during the covid epidemic and i think
they're trying to
keep their power really in there and
they're fiddling and they're tweaking
and they're intervening
too much i think we either need to tell
people who are thinking about going on
holiday
that it is safe to go to spain or france
or wherever
or or it isn't i just don't think
there's going to be
enough change in the next two or three
weeks to justify
allowing someone to go to um spain for
example
and then suddenly changing the rules and
charging them seventeen hundred
eighteen hundred pounds to quarantine in
one of these
special hotels tell them now they can go
or tell them
they can't go this constant churning i
think is
is is just too many bureaucrats too many
politicians
trying to interfere too much in people's
lives but ministers would say it's not
about power it's nothing to do with
power they're responding to the
information that they receive and they
can only act
on circumstances as they change and they
change
all the time they change a little bit
all the time but not a great deal is
what i would say sorry i don't know
whether you were talking to me or susie
then but uh
come in susie uh yeah thank you
um well they change according to winning
variance
there's a couple of things at play here
the first is that um
there are new variants that arise there
are other countries
where you can all it's already well for
this country to say hey you can travel
now you can
you can fly it's safe it doesn't mean
the place you're going to
is the same situation or indeed the same
standards for what is safe
as we do the other thing you've got to
bear in mind is that the people that are
making these rules
have never ever ever in their lives as
far as i can tell
ever booked a holiday in a year's time
and had to save up and pay for it
they go on holiday tomorrow when they
feel like it when they just pay full
price
so they have no concept of the fact that
someone has paid in advance and booked a
long time ago
and i have um a great deal of sympathy
for people who have been
desperate for the past year to perhaps
go to see
another country to see family to see
friends see people they've been really
separated from or perhaps they've been
stuck abroad because of work and they
couldn't get back
got a great deal of sympathy for those
people but it's been quite clear
from the time from the moment the prime
minister said hey everyone
you can go abroad again let's all raw
summer holidays we'll go off i'll get a
big red bus and
sing like cliff richard it was quite
apparent from the moment that happened
that it was a terrible terrible idea
because it was done
not because it was safe or because it
was a fabulous thing we could all do
safely but in order to appease the
the tourism lobby and the industry and
the jobs that he didn't want to protect
through furlough for any longer
that's why it's all been allowed to
happen so so do you think that
uh as tim does that that the government
is tinkering unnecessarily or
rowing back from a a bad decision in the
first instance as you describe
they've made they've made a decision on
the basis of politics
rather than health or science or need
and then
that's got themselves in a situation
where they then have to tinker and
change and go oops no it's not quite
what we thought ordered it
and then you know they're just careering
down the side of a mountain
and trying to correct the course very
slightly as they're going
ignoring the fact we are still careering
downwards um
it's the initial decision and it's the
initial
it's the mindset it's the way they look
at these problems
which is that the money has to be found
from somewhere
uh and you know it's not us that's gonna
find it it's someone else that's got to
find it it's that fundamental
difficulty in grasping the fact we are
in all this together
um that has led us to the point where
they're making bad decisions and
that we make one bad decision you've got
to make a thousand different bad
decisions trying to make up for it
haven't you
tim let's move on to the daily mirror um
equally uh depressing
they're looking at covered rules and bad
weather their headline there
holes hell well can i make a confession
jillian it talks about um
august in the uk possibly being cool and
showery
compared to the heat we had a couple of
weeks ago when i've
been really fair boring boring
englishman i would prefer
cool and showery weather i of course
would wish
up on no one the kind of showers that
led to the flooding we've seen in places
like
london of course but yeah i'm someone
who just really does struggle to sleep
in the heat and so if i did have the
choice i would choose the
the slightly damper the damper weather
but for yeah
as the mirror suggests for for people
going abroad in the search for sun
it may well be that they're not going to
have very settled weather either so
the poor tourism industry you know where
a lot of jobs and a lot of livelihoods
are involved
and you know it's just another bad sign
for an industry that is probably going
to have
longer run consequences from this covid
um
this period in our history than almost
any other industry
yeah and then we're also looking at the
the fact suzie that uh spain could be
added to the quarantine list
yeah and one of the one of the lines
that's really interesting in the story
is this evening about the sort of the
holiday chaos
and all things could get added to the
amber list that you've already booked
somewhere and you know a couple before
you go it gets added to the ambulance
kind of thing
there's also warnings that you could be
abroad and in another country and it
gets added to the red list which would
mean mandatory quarantine costing 1800
pounds
in in a hotel room perhaps with your
entire family 10 days
on your return so you know going abroad
has always been a bit of a dodgy deal
uh in this pandemic and it looks like
they're prepared to admit that it was a
bad
idea put it that way so i'll just be
very cautious about going abroad
especially
if there's any possibility that
countries could get added to the red
list while you're away yeah but but it's
so difficult now though because people
that have uh
booked holidays when they look at the
the start facts facing them that they
could end up
in a red list country do they cancel the
holiday can they cancel the holiday
because they're not being forbidden
to travel so can they even get their
money back at this stage
the best thing if you are a wealthier
person
uh if you can afford to work from home
then
1800 quid in a hotel or having to
isolate for 10 days
is not too much of a trauma it can be
done if you
are in a lower paid job if you cannot
afford 1800 pounds
in a official government quarantine then
you can't you just have to
not go on holiday because you lose your
job when you come home and
that's enough and as soon as you were
saying earlier it isn't just good people
going on holiday lots of families now
modern families
are separated across continents and so a
lot of people
and this is people that are loved ones
people who are perhaps sick or ill you
know
or you know their later years they
haven't seen for 18 months
so messing about you're not just messing
about with changing these rules with
people's holidays
you're you're messing around with
people's ability to see their most loved
and precious relatives
yes no no very very uh difficult for
quite a few people actually and tim
let's also have a look at this story and
for the break
stonehenge tunnel that's been blocked
take us into this story and you
must just say uh you're broadcasting
from salisbury
so you have some inside intel well i
don't know whether i have inside um
intel jillian but i certainly have sort
of
you know a real passion about this um
story you know stonehenge is
one of the most extraordinary gifts from
our um
you know ancestors from our history and
it's a difficult situation either way
because at the moment it's surrounded by
traffic and pollution and so the idea of
this
tunnel is to try and avoid the um the
bottlenecks of traffic that surround
this ancient
um monument and but the trouble with the
tunnel is um it's not just the stones
that we're familiar with i think are on
screen now
with stonehenge the whole area is of
rich
archaeological series of treasure troves
and there has always been concern that
building a tunnel
through this land would disrupt um
precious gifts from history that we
haven't discovered yet so
i have i have it's not good either way
what happens uh in the future
for um stonehenge but i i think this
tunnel idea was probably the worst of
all options
yes well the high court judge quashed
the plans to construct the tunnel for
the a303
which runs past the monument so uh that
will be good news
in your eyes i i can imagine thanks very
much
both for the moment we are going to take
a break coming up questions over whether
tory donors have too much
political influence we'll discuss that
next animal
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me tonight
susie bonnie face and tim montgomery
let us pick up where we left off we're
gonna have a look at the ft
now and this story about tory donors
getting meetings securing meetings with
boris johnson and rishi sunek and the
parties denying that there's any link
between
uh cash donations and government policy
susie
yeah there's a complete disconnect
between giving put money to politicians
and politicians doing what you want
that's never ever happened in any
time of human history we know about um
some donors having uh you know over
many administrations having access to
downing street
uh both tories and labor um but
particularly in recent years with tories
with
uh leaders club dinners and so on if you
give a certain amount you are invited to
sit on a table with boris johnson at a
conservative ball and things like this
and we know that if you uh give over a
certain amount you can get invited to
regular dinners in downing street with
previous prime ministers
what this is about is an entirely secret
group
known sort of offhand as the 250 club
which is for anybody who has donated
more than 250
000 pounds to the conservative party and
it's not mentioned
in conservative party literature there's
a minister quoted in this story who
doesn't know anything about
it um not everyone in the club has given
the full 250k
but those who have and those who are in
the club
get to meet once a month with either
rishi sunak or boris johnson
online or in person and in those
meetings
they have used those meetings some of
these donors reportedly
to ask for cuts to public services which
of course
isn't going to affect any of them if
they've got 250 grand in their back
pocket to give to a politician
and lower taxes which of course would
affect them
and would also affect the rest of us as
well tim um
just to bring tim in there um this all
sounds a little bit fishy doesn't it tim
i have to agree unfortunately i'd like
to disagree with susie on
i don't know how we finance political
parties to be honest
because there's no easy way of doing it
political parties can be captured by big
unions they can be captured by big
business or they can be captured by
small interest groups
and then if you have state funding it
means that you essentially get
established
parties you know having an advantage
over insurgent parties that can't raise
money so
there's no easy way of doing this but my
main
worry in some of the subtext of the ft
story
is that a preponderance of the money
currently going to the tory party
um comes from property developers and
city of london interests and i don't
think that necessarily means that
there's sort of a direct connection
between
a donor wanting something and getting a
special benefit although i'm afraid that
probably does happen sometimes
but i think you probably sort of changes
the mindset of the conservative party
the
the leaders of the conservative they
start thinking much more about the
property sector and the city sector
rather than say manufacturing you know
yes industries that are further outside
of london
that's a real danger for me of this yeah
uh susie we're going to change the gear
completely and for the very serious
issue of um
pies should they be banned from football
matches this is in
the star the all-important question you
know what no they shouldn't be banned
from football matches they should be
served at downing street and people who
attend football matches should get to go
to downing street to talk to the prime
minister just as often as he talks to
millionaires
oh that way maybe we'd have a prime
minister who knows what the hell he's
doing
i love how you owe the stories together
well done
susie and tim thank you so much